we start out with a question from the
Discord server every every week that we
do this and this week the question reads
as follows dear B&H is there evidence
that unvaccinated individuals are at
risk from intimate relationships with
people who are vaxed if so is there a
time at which these relationships could
become safe for example waiting one year
after someone was vaxed additionally are
the risks
significant um the what the person who
wrote in uh who who emailed me with this
question also did say although I didn't
post it here somehow um she knows that
we've talked about this a little bit and
and have said before that it didn't seem
like maybe a big deal maybe there's more
information yeah so what we have said
before is that the issue of
shedding is hard to Fathom because to
the extent that an individual can
tolerate whatever it is that they're
being inoculated with even with high
risks the fact that most people seem to
get away with it uh suggest that
whatever they might be shedding into the
environment through breathing for
example would be such a tiny fraction of
that that it's hard to imagine that
absent an extreme sensitivity that it
would have any measurable effect but
there's been a lot of work uh in recent
times with respect to particular kinds
of shedding so sexual shedding which
might be especially a hazard to women
during sexual intercourse the shedding
of uh either proteins or mRNA templates
themselves in breast milk is a
possibility so I think we cannot
discount the possibility that in
Intimate
Relationships there are kinds of
shedding that might
matter now with respect to a baby the
vulnerability would be much greater
because the vulnerability of infants in
their first year is
substantial um so that is something I
would concern myself with um as far as
sexual
shedding uh I could see it being an
issue I would certainly imagine that it
is an issue that would decrease over
time with that said we do not have a
good sense of how quickly the body rids
itself of these mRNA templates the right
insane stabilization of the MRNA
templates with the pseudo urines for
which amazingly enough these uh mRNA
so-called vaccines were given a Nobel
Prize um means that they are not
degradable by normal processes and the
evidence is that they persist for a very
long time now they have to be degraded
by just simply so fastic breakage cell
turnover happens right there there are
some some of our cell lines last almost
as long as we do um but most cell lines
have a considerably shorter lifespan
yeah but the problem is even cell
lifespan does not inherently limit these
that's true uh the Persistence of these
transcripts they could get taken up and
effectively um
reinoculate uh cells that weren't
initially
transfected
so for reasons that just come down to
basic physics and Physiology you would
imagine that there would be a
degradation of all of the consequences
of these things other than the rare case
where a stem cell line had been
genetically altered which is possible
especially with the contamination with
the plasmids the sv40 promoter the
mechanisms for genes to be altered are
there in most cases if genes were
altered in a cell that
cell would likely also have been
transfected with the MRNA and therefore
would likely be destroyed by the immune
system in the case of a stem cell that
might not be the case so let's just say
one would imagine that these risks
whatever they are decrease over time
fewer of the shots you've had the better
the longer ago it was the
better um I don't know how a world is
going to deal
with you know you
can't avoid the world of those who got
these transfected elements so yep um you
know I I would just say your normal
instincts probably apply the number
matters the time it's been since matters
and um
the harm while Unforgivable at the level
of these things having been
administered
is something you
can assess its bounds roughly by the
fact that most people who got
them um are you know may have been
temporarily sickened but are
[Music]
okay